[Music]
we all played with some pretty weird
toys when we were kids
and we weren't the only ones do you know
what other kids of flavor
stay tuned for some bizarre Chinese toys
and the Barbie doll that caused a lot of
controversy don't forget to hit that
notification bell then never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out 10 strangest toys
from around the world
German windup toys let's just jump right
in with toys you find in any decent
horror movie remember those wind-up toys
that would start drumming or do other
strange things that are actually quite
creepy
well they originated from Germany check
out this wind-up monkey it looks totally
unamused at the entire situation but
when you wind it up it'll start drumming
and here's another one with the monkey
on a motorcycle when you wind this one
up the motorcycle will drive around
which makes it less creepy but we still
can't get over the look to these toys
the way they look at a strange element
to the entire thing it's no wonder they
appear in horror movies these toys date
back to the 15th century and were first
created by a German toymaker and became
pretty popular even Leonardo da Vinci
caught on board with his wind-up lion
for the King of France the toys became
extremely popular in the 16th and 17th
century and were mass-produced in an
attempt to create lifelike figurines
well as lifelike as they possibly can
which actually made them pretty creepy
toilet trouble from the US which flush
will cause the gush toilet trouble is a
fairly recent invention but that doesn't
mean it's not strange the hall toilet
related games are immediately funny but
this one is just so bizarre and of
course it comes from the US and then
gets distributed to the UK and plenty of
other countries toilet trouble is
actually a pretty fun game but we just
can't get on board the concept is pretty
simple you get a toy toilet and then
each player takes turns spinning the
toilet paper roll and flushing the
toilet one unlucky player will get their
face frayed by water that's inside the
toilet yeah we have no idea why this is
a game either but it's definitely proof
that it's not just old games that have a
strange factor haha
toilet humor always a classic the best
part about this game is you
fill the toilet on your own and we
suspect there are some sneaky people out
there who might fill it with something
other than water Chinese face changing
dolls Chinese face changing dolls are a
part of Chinese tradition and folklore
although a well-known toy in China this
item might seem quite terrifying
anywhere else legend states that the
ancient people of China painted their
faces to scare wild animals the small
figurine comes with four different faces
and they change when you pull its hat in
front of its face and lift it back up
each doll comes with unique fantastic
designs that change with each face
including human faces as well as animals
to represent the Fulco culture the toys
themselves were inspired by the
traditional face changing artistic
performance called the Sichuan opera
which dates all the way back to the 13th
century in the performance just like
these dolls the actors would quickly
change their faces and by quickly we
mean the actors could easily change 10
masks in just 20 seconds it's no wonder
this Chinese tradition got turned into
actual dolls with changing faces in
modern days this tradition got upgraded
by high-tech lasers and other twinkling
lights but the dolls stay true to the
old-school face changing performances
what do you think about the toy is it
normal or strange crying baby doll from
the UK you can find these baby dolls
just about anywhere as their popularity
seems to travel the world the idea
behind these dolls is for children to
get some responsibilities kudos and
learn what it's like to take care of an
actual baby like themselves these baby
dolls might not be as popular today
because let's be honest kids can learn
the same things in so many other ways
but a baby doll crying back in the day
was actually some pretty advanced stuff
while nowadays it's just strange
depending on who made the baby doll you
got some of them were also able to make
real crying noises but others just
stayed silent 12 tears poured down their
faces check out this baby doll in a
bunny costume you don't see many of
these nowadays also why do they only cry
sure they stop when they're comforted
but none of them laugh as if all the
babies were depressed during
time stay tuned for some more weird toys
that are actually quite a tradition in
these next countries and for those who
enjoy relaxing too ASMR we've got some
for you as well but first check out this
familiar Russian toy Russian matryoshka
most people have probably heard about
the strange dolls that have become quite
a tradition in Russia their origin dates
back to 1890 and they were born at a
children's education workshop a
matryoshka doll also known as a Russian
nesting doll or stacking dolls is a set
of wooden dolls of decreasing size
placed one inside another the original
dolls consisted of seven figurines but
depending on the sizes of the biggest
one you can actually fit many more
inside these dolls were extremely
popular with Russian artists who
experimented with various designs and
made almost every doll as unique as
possible there's also a legend that
states the first stall of this kind was
actually brought on a Japanese island by
a Russian monk you can also find fruit
versions of the matryoshka as well as
everything else that can be carved into
wood the dolls can be used to teach
counting shapes and motor skills but
most of the time people just want to get
to the tiniest doll they can find in the
set have you ever played with a Russian
matryoshka let us know in the comments
Chinese infinite shipping envelope toy
if you find the sound of those Instagram
ASMR videos oddly relaxing you know like
tearing an envelope or the sound of
opening that Mac box from Apple then
you'll love this China knows what's up
with the infinite shipping envelope toy
it's a simple keychain toy that comes
with a speaker at the bottom the
keychain is a simple mock-up of an
envelope tearing every time you pull on
the tearing it produces a satisfying
sound of what it's actually like to tear
an envelope and who doesn't love opening
an envelope despite the fact that this
is one amazing invention it's also
incredibly strange but in the current
world where satisfying sounds are a
theme this toy definitely comes in handy
yeah we're confused at the same time we
want it more than anything else
it'll cost you about $10 but the joy of
hearing an envelope being torn over
/ priceless Japanese Kobe dolls meet
Japanese Kobe dolls a traditional and
extremely popular doll from Japan and
yes even though they're not dolls in the
traditional sense of the word it's just
what they're called these figurines come
in all sorts of shapes and all sorts of
sizes they're essentially wooden toys
with movable parts and bulging eyes that
become long sticks the toys were popular
in the 18th and 19th century and were
soon distributed to just about any shop
out there they're pretty small in size
but as an antique they're an extremely
popular toy with antique sellers can you
imagine people playing with toys like
these they seem pretty terrifying for
kids guests bulging eyes were a popular
thing back in the day huh some of the
toys also came with wind-up music and a
few other interesting quirks these Kobe
dolls are extremely hard to get outside
of Japan these days and can sell for an
impressive amount especially if they
were made with fine wood we've add even
now you can find plenty of families that
still own at least one Kobe figurine but
we have a feeling most kids have moved
on to play with other toys American pogo
ball if you're an 80s and 90s kid this
might ring a bell
the pogo ball was extremely popular in
the US during the 80s except the entire
concept of it just seems a bit bizarre
and we can't even imagine how kids got
the hang of it all you had to do was to
stand on the ball and bounce yeah it
might seem easy but it was like totally
hard af there wasn't anything to strap
your feet to it you just kind of had to
balance it out and jump and even getting
on there in the first place was its own
challenge and if you wanted to jump
higher and longer you had to practice a
lot we can see how Pogo ball wouldn't
have the same effect today but in the
80s the US and Brazil really went in for
this toy if you were cool enough you can
even master some awesome pogo ball
tricks but if you were just normal like
the rest of us the pogo ball just left
you with really sore legs the next day
fortunately nowadays we have trampolines
for this the Russian packing chicken toy
and we're going back to Russia with this
one ever heard of a pecking chicken toy
it's as strange as
might sound but it's actually a
traditional and pretty popular toy in
Russia it's a wooden toy with chickens
on top in a ball with a string at the
bottom you hold the toy with the handle
and spin the ball string around to get
the chicken mechanism going and then the
chickens start pecking at whatever's on
the surface that's it that's the whole
point to the entire toy it might seem
strange but the chickens actually
produce quite a satisfying sound as
their wooden beaks hit the surface it's
one of those toys where people outside
of Russia will have a hard time
understanding but we bet most Russian
kids own the toy or played with it when
they went to Grandma's house people
would even put random things in the
middle of the chickens and then part of
the fun was to make sure those things
never fell off so yeah it might seem
like a strange toy but we can totally
get how this could actually be tons of
fun totally stylin tattoos Barbie have
you ever noticed how the most bizarre
toys always come from the USA like this
Barbie controversy it dates back to 2009
when Mattel wanted to try something new
and it really didn't go down well meet
totally stylin tattoos Barbie which
comes with tattoo stickers kids can put
anywhere they want some of these tattoos
include very questionable designs like
Ken's name written inside a heart making
it seem like it's okay for kids to
tattoo someone's name on yourself most
adults can agree that this is usually a
big no-no the tattooed Barbie returned
in 2011 as tokidoki Barbie but it was
only sold as part of a collector set
meant for adults but at that time many
pointed out that the tattooed barbie is
actually more diverse than the Barbies
usually produced by Mattel while kids
are definitely too young to get tattoos
themselves is there really any harm and
being exposed to them during playtime
what do you think about tattooed Barbie
is putting tattoo stickers on a Barbie
really off limits or is it just another
way of introducing diversity to kids
from a young age feel free to let us
know in the comments and that's it for
our video thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]